is nebulizing glutathione, okay, or a cancer patient.
I heard you say it can be good for lung issues.
So, when would somebody nebulize glutathione?
So, nebulized glutathione could be really good for the brain.
It could be a good way to get glutathione in your system.
So, years ago, we used to see a lot of patients that had Lyme disease,
and a lot of patients with fibromyalgia and other autoimmune issues.
And we used to use nebulized glutathione in our office.
And part of the reason why we used nebulized glutathione is that
there wasn't real, at that time, there were el glutathione was not on the market.
And liposomal gland as glutathione didn't exist as a supplement.
So, glutathione is extremely poorly absorbed.
Now, all the glutathione in the market that's in a capsule form,
that's a powder is el glutathione, it's much better absorbed.
The liposomal glutathione is even better absorbed.
So, there really isn't a need to use nebulized glutathione.
Except if a person has lung issues, person has lung infections,
lung disorder, autoimmune attacks to their lung,
using nebulized glutathione could be a extremely beneficial.
However, should a cancer patient ever use glutathione?
In general, no, they shouldn't.
Remember, glutathione, remember, when I just said a few questions back,
that cancer cells are already at a higher resting state of oxidative stress
near the lethal dose crossover of oxidative stress where they could die.
So, your therapies with cancer are oxidative to help push them past that lethal dose
to help cancer cells die.
Glutathione is an antioxidant.
It's the strongest cellular antioxidant.
So, if you're going to take glutathione when you have cancer,
you have the potential of keeping cancer cells alive.
So, we don't want to do that unless it tests perfect for you,
which is a few and far between.
Not very many cancer patients have I used glutathione with.
So, in general, I would say no, don't use glutathione.
But what if I have cancer, but now I have this lung infection that I'm dealing with?
Well, if you have a lung infection that you're dealing with,
I wouldn't necessarily use glutathione anyhow.
It's a lung infection.
You want to use something that's going to help kill the infection.
Nebulizing hydrogen peroxide.
That's formula that's on the member site home page.
Is the formula for it's the Mercola formula for how you have to water
down the hydrogen peroxide to the right percentage.
And nebulizing hydrogen peroxide can be extremely beneficial
for any lung infections.
It can also be beneficial for cancer patients.
If you're really into nebulizing it,
you want to nebulize things.
Nebulizing hydrogen peroxide can be beneficial for cancers.
But certainly lung issues, it's going to be more beneficial for.
If you have lung infections, you can nebulize colloidal silver.
There's other things you can nebulize as well.
And why would a person nebulize?
Well, you're getting it right into the lung.
It's easier to cross the alveolar space, the lung barrier.
So you have barriers.
You have a gut barrier.
So if you have damage to your gut,
a lot of supplements are food that you're eating.
Maybe you're not absorbing high percentage,
but you could absorb a lot through the through the barrier of your lung.
So it can increase the absorption rate by doing nebulized different things.
However, you got to be careful if you're nebulizing it all the time.
You can be irritating to your lungs too.
So you got to be careful in that.
So there's a balance there.
So in general, I would say no cancer patients should not be nebulizing gluteus diet.